مرحبًا أجنبيًا ،
أنا سعيد وأبحث في كيفية
اكتشاف أجهزة الكمبيوتر للتعرف على وجوه الأشخاص وتصنيفها ، فقد
عمل النظام الذي كنت أستخدمه جيدًا
على وجه صديقي ذي البشرة الفاتحة ، ولكن
عندما يتعلق الأمر باكتشاف وجهي ،
لم يكن ذلك جيدًا حتى أرتدي
القناع الأبيض ،
نعم ، أعتقد أن الذكاء الاصطناعي عنصري لأن
البيانات التي يتم تعلمها منها هي من
البشر والبشر في
الثقافات المختلفة عنصرية ،
لذا فالمسألة ليست عنصرية في الذكاء الاصطناعي ،
إنها مسألة ما نضعه
في أنظمة الذكاء الاصطناعي التي  نحن نتخذ
قرارات إشكالية في
الصحة الرقمية الأجنبية لـ AIS والقضية الرئيسية التي
وجدناها أنه على الرغم من تدريب نماذج الذكاء الاصطناعي
للنظر في أنواع مختلفة من
أمراض الأمراض ،
إلا أن هذه النماذج كانت جيدة جدًا في
تحديد المهم وأحيانًا  ليست
معلومات ديموغرافية مهمة عن
المرضى ، فقد تمكنت من تحديد
عمر جنس المريض
ولكن حتى عندما لم يتم تدريبه على
تحديد العرق وهذا هو السبب في أننا
لا نعرف كيف يمكن للشريان الأبهر
القيام بذلك
وهذا هو السبب حتى لو كان  يتخذ نموذج الذكاء الاصطناعي
قراراته بناءً على
معلومات العرق عندما لا يلعب العنصري
أي دور في الصلة السريرية ، فإنه لا
يزال قادرًا على استخدام تلك المعلومات
التي لا أعتقد أن البشر يمكنهم بعد ذلك
تحديد سبب اتخاذ هذا
القرار وهو  لماذا هو ضار
وقد يسبب خطرًا
[موسيقى] [
موسيقى]
التعرف على الوجه هو نوع من الذكاء الاصطناعي
ويميل إلى أن يكون أه متحيزًا ضد
الأشخاص ذوي البشرة الداكنة فهو يميل إلى
التعرف على أه الرجال أفضل من النساء ، فهو
يميل إلى التعرف على الأشخاص بالضوء
البشرة أفضل من الأشخاص ذوي البشرة الداكنة
وتميل إلى التعرف على النساء ذوات
البشرة الداكنة أسوأ بكثير مما يتعرف على
الرجال ذوي البشرة الفاتحة أه إذا كانت التكنولوجيا
تعمل بشكل سيئ أعتقد أنه لا ينبغي
استخدامها في الشرطة ،
نعم
الذكاء الاصطناعي ليس مسارًا لا يمكن إيقافه ، إنه
مجرد  الرياضيات
الأجنبية
[تصفيق]